[Music]
the haunting of Hill House was and still
remains my favorite show on Netflix the
10 episode masterpiece perfectly
encapsulated a horrifying ghost story
that didn't need to rely on jump scares
or cheap tricks to fool the audience and
at its heart it possessed a personal
tale about family to me the first season
felt perfect to the point that I wasn't
even sure if it needed a second one but
for better or worse
Netflix have announced that there will
indeed be a follow-up in 2020 called the
haunting of Bligh Manor throughout this
video I'll be discussing all of the
details that we know so far about the
show and the meaning behind its title
there will be spoilers here so if you
don't want to know anything about the
show so far or where I could go then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I'm definition and
here's my breakdown of everything that
you need to know about the haunting of
Bligh Manor from the title I think it's
pretty safe to say that the original
cast of season 1 will not be returning
Bligh Manor did not feature in their
backstory so they would have none of the
emotional ties that were so prevalent in
the first season I also feel like that
journey wrapped up so perfectly with the
father's sacrifice that it would be a
waste to pull them back into it
especially with the deal that he made
with the house to save his family
instead the show will likely follow a
brand new cast of characters who may or
may not already be aware of the family
from the first season but where does the
name fly man had come from and what can
we take from this well Bligh Manor is
taken from an 1898 novel called the turn
of the screw in that book a governess
and the two children that she cares for
live in a country house and slowly
uncovered the more sinister side to it
if that sounds familiar then you'll be
pleased to know that the novel was
reportedly the inspiration behind the
Nicole Kidman film the others similar to
the first season at the turn of the
screw deals heavily with mental health
and over the years many fans and critics
of the novel have debated over whether
the ghosts in the story actually exist
or if they are merely figment
the governesses imagination so when will
it be set well personally I believe that
though the novel is set in the past the
Netflix adaptation will take place in
modern day to avoid comparisons to the
others and to stick more in line with
the original season the haunting of
Bligh manor is set to be released in
2020 so stay tuned to the channel for
more updates as they come out obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
news of the second season and if you're
excited to see it if you enjoyed this
video then please like it and make sure
you check out my breakdown of everything
we know so far about Russian doll season
2 which will be linked at the end this
is a channel for people who are heavy
into horror so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
you